Okay, so good morning. We finished the
Bronze Age today with the Indus Valley
civilization.
So we've done Egypt, we've done
Mesopotamia. Now we're doing the Indus
Valley civilization.
And today I'm going to look at three
questions, okay?
First of all, what is it that makes
Indus Valley civilization distinct or
different from other civilizations?
Second is
why did it decline?
Uh they reached their peak about 2600 to
1900 uh BCE and then for the next three
to four hundred years they declined and
ultimately disappeared.
Okay, why did that happen? And the last
question is
what is their legacy? Uh what's their
contribution to
uh development of Western civilization?
Okay? All right.
So
let's um look at the Indus Valley
civilization. To do so, we need we need
to first understand
the world at this time. This is about
to
uh 2000 BC, okay? This this is what we
call the Middle Bronze Age because most
people were using bronze for weapons,
for tools.
Um so
over here is Egypt.
And as we discussed, by far Egypt is the
wealthiest, most advanced civilization
in the Bronze Age.
Um over here
across the Red Sea is Arabia.
Okay? And even though Arabia isn't
really discussed that much
um in world history, it's still
significant because it's part of the
trading network. Okay? So the Arabia,
it's mainly nomads
uh who take goods from Mesopotamia over
to Egypt and then into the
Mediterranean, which accesses all of
Europe.
Um
this is um
uh Sumer
which is the beginning of
the Mesopotamian civilization, okay? Up
up here is Anatolia.
The Levant.
Um and then the Indus Valley
civilization
is over here.
And today um it would cover the the
countries of Afghanistan
Pakistan and Northwest India. Okay? What
makes In- Indus Valley civilization
important is
um it's really by the coast
which allows it to access
uh Mesopotamia and Egypt.
Okay? Meaning during the Bronze Age
these three civilizations, Egyptians,
Mesopotamians and the Indus Valley
civilization were heavily interconnected
through trade.
And um Indus Valley civilization
um what they what was unique to them are
certain products.
For example, indigo dye which was really
sought after in Mesopotamia and in
Egypt. Um their handicrafts, their
jewelry were also very famous throughout
uh the world.
Um
usually traded with Sumer and Egypt by
trading with the Gulf state nations of
Bahrain and Oman and Dubai, okay? And
they actually had a colony
by the the Persian Gulf.
All right? Uh this civilization was so
good at trading that we believe
they even traded with China, okay? Which
is pretty far away, but their ships were
were were huge and they were very good
navigators.
Um as the Bronze Age developed over time
um bronze was in heavy demand and the
main components of bronze are copper and
tin.
Tin is mainly found in the mountains of
Afghanistan over here, okay?
Which meant
the I- Indus Valley civilization started
to now expand over to Afghanistan in
order to access the tin trade.
Okay? So tin was really sought after,
but there was also another um stone
called uh lapis lazuli
which is really sought after by the
Egyptians for its spiritual and
aesthetic qualities.
Okay?
And over here
um because of the trade
uh with Afgha- Afghanistan, language
started to develop into Anatolia and
Mesop- Mesopotamia, okay? And as well
because of this trade in Afghanistan
um new civilizations started to develop
as well.
And they're not as advanced, as large as
the three major ones, but they're still
pretty advanced. So for example, up here
is what we call uh the Oxus Valley
civilization.
The technical term used by
archaeologists are the Bactrian
Mar- Margiana Archaeological Complex.
You don't have to know this, okay? It's
called BMAC.
What makes this civilization important
is it interacts it interacts with the
Steppe people, okay? Called the
Andronovo
culture.
So as you can see, the Indus Valley
civilization through its partners
uh the Oxus
Valley civilization um and its colonies
over here
now trade with the entire world. There's
no piece of the Western world that Indus
Valley civilization does not touch.
Okay? Does that make sense?
So this is a world about 2500 to 2000
BCE. It's a world that's heavily
interconnected and there are two major
sources of demand.
Uh the Egyptians are extremely wealthy
and they want these valuable jewelry and
handicrafts for their burials, okay?
That's the one source of heavy heavy
demand. The main source source of demand
is actually Mesopotamia where the
city-states of Sumer are fighting wars
against each other.
And in wars, bronze makes a huge
difference because bronze armor
um is more it's much more stronger than
copper armor. Okay? So these two places
are driving demand and as such the Indus
Valley civilization is growing wealthy
through trade.
Okay?
Does that make sense? Any questions so
far before I continue?
Okay. So even though the Indus Valley
civilization is connected with Egypt and
Mesopotamia, it's a rather different
civilization.
Okay? So the first thing
uh that makes Indus Valley civilization
interesting is it's a huge area. It's
actually in terms of size larger than
Egypt and Mesopotamia combined.
It has a population of at at its peak
about 5 million people. Okay? So this is
a huge area.
What's really interesting is we have
found no evidence
of any organized warfare in this region
during this time.
The reason why is this region is
connected through trade.
Okay?
So what we have found is five major
urban centers
in the Indus Valley civilization.
And these urban centers
you can consider to be what we call
value
adding
processing
centers. Okay? These are urban centers
that specialize in taking raw goods
like metals and um
agricultural products and turning them
into
finished products like jewelry,
handicrafts
to be shipped, to be traded with mainly
Mesopotamia, but also Egypt and possibly
China as well. It also goes north to the
Oxus Valley civilization which then
trades with the Steppe people, the
Andronovo culture, okay? What we know as
the Yamnaya people.
All right?
So um this trade network
um it's very very complex
and everyone is involved in some
capacity in this trade network.
Okay? So that's the first thing that's
interesting about the
um Indus Valley civilization. They trade
internally peacefully, they trade
externally peacefully as well. We have
absolutely no evidence
that they ever had organized warfare. We
have absolutely no evidence that they
have any intention of organized warfare.
Meaning we have not found any weapons.
We have found tools, we found uh hunting
weapons, we have not found like maybe
armor and helmets.
Okay? Yeah. Is there any particular
reason that we suspect that there is no
organized warfare in that particular
region? Yeah, great question. So how do
we know there's no organized warfare?
So we know there's a lot of organized
warfare in Mesopotamia and other places
because because of what of what we um
have dug up. So we look at cities, we
see parts of the city that have been
built on top of or destroyed. Meaning
um there might have been some fires or
there might have been some warfare,
okay? But with the with these five urban
centers that we've dug up, we have we
have found them pretty intact. Meaning
they were not built on top of or they
were not destroyed uh during the pro-
when they were around. Okay, so that's
the first major piece of evidence. The
second major piece of evidence is uh
we've dug up their graves. So, if you
look at um maybe the civilizations of
the Indus Valley culture or Mesopotamia,
they tend to bury warriors with their
weapons.
Okay, so
um you know, helmets and armor.
But when we when we dug up the IVC
culture people, first of all, we don't
find a distinct cast of warriors.
Also, we don't find any helmets or armor
or weapons. Okay, so that's what led us
to believe they don't engage in
organized warfare. But there's also
evidence to suggest our evidence is not
solid, okay? The first piece of evidence
is they don't bury their dead.
Um these people don't have a tradition
of burying their dead. Some are buried,
okay? But they but not everyone is
buried.
Um second of all,
we don't know where they buried their
dead. We assume they buried their dead
uh in the cities, but that may not be
true, okay? So,
um the evidence leans towards they were
peaceful civilization,
but as we dis- as we dig up more and
more over time, we may discover
this is not true.
Okay? But the right now the evidence
suggests they were peaceful.
And also what's really important about
the IVC, the Indus Valley civilization,
is this is a new discovery. We've only
known known about them for the past 100
years.
So, what's interesting is the Indians
themselves never knew they existed. It
was the British who discovered these
cities and start um the work in in
archaeology to start to um reconstruct
their civilization.
Okay?
All right. But thanks for the question.
Okay. So, um as I said, uh what's in
for- the first thing that's interesting
about the civilization is it was it was
relatively peaceful, okay? Compared with
what's happening in Mesopo- Mesopotamia.
The second thing that was interesting
for us is
uh and surprising is for a very large
civilization, they are egalitarian.
Okay? Meaning
in Mesopo- Mesopotamia, when we look at
these old cities, Ur and Uruk, there
were these huge palaces and temples,
which suggested um a culture a culture
of power in the priesthood and in the
king, okay?
But
when we look at these five urban centers
of the IVC, there are no there are no
palaces, there are no
um temples. Okay? In fact, these cities
are extremely well designed.
There are these walls
around the city,
and then as you go into the city, you're
able to access every single part of the
city.
But if you were to go into a city, say
in Sumer,
if you go into the city, you're only
able to access the temple or the palace,
okay? So, authority is centralized
in
in Sumer.
Whereas authority is sort of
decentralized
in
um
the IVC. Now, here here's a question. If
we know if we suspect they are not
engaged in warfare, why do they have
walls?
Why would there there are a lot of walls
inside these cities. Why there walls?
Can any- anyone guess?
Okay, customs, taxes, okay?
Meaning this is again a value added
adding process center, and the way they
survived economically is by collecting
tolls and customs on people who trade.
And the way the way they collect taxes
is
when you enter the city, um you have to
go to the customs house,
and then you pay whatever
um
is required of you, and then and you can
access the city, okay? And that's the
way they
socialized centrally controlled
uh the economy and trade in the IVC.
Um these cities are amazing.
These are the first people to invent the
seat toilet. The private seat toilet.
This is about the year
BCE, okay? So, if you if you go into
these cities, you'll find that in
private homes, everyone has a private
toilet.
And then the feces is put into a sewage
system, and the water flushes it out.
Okay? That's that's pretty amazing.
Uh these are people who are very
concerned about the well-being of all
its citizens.
So, when we look at skeletal remains
through DNA analysis, we've discovered
the
the majority of the people ate about the
same high quality of food. Okay, there
wasn't any disparities
uh
between people as you would find in
other civilizations.
At least half the people, we think,
lived past the age of 55.
That was an amazing achievement
uh back then.
In terms of innovation, they have
reservoirs, okay? They also have public
baths. They also had really amazing
things called wind towers. I'm not I'm
not sure if you've studied these wind
towers, but they're basically air
conditioners. What they do is
um these are high towers,
and there is a
um hole on top, right? So, what happens
is
um the higher the air is, the cooler it
is, right? So, this wind that's cool
gets trapped into the wind tower. It
comes down, and it pushes out the hot
air from the other side. And this is
what cools
the houses
um
in the summer.
Okay, and this is a pretty advanced
technology.
Another really cool thing about the IVC
is even though it covers a huge area,
they have standardized weights and
measurements.
Okay? They have standardized weights and
Which means that every brick that they
have is the same size.
Which means that their buildings, their
their structures
are extremely
uh stable
and resilient. That's why 5,000 years
later, we still have their cities
intact. Yeah, you can actually go to the
cities and live in them.
That's how that's how um
stable the technology was, okay? So,
this is a pretty
um advanced civilization.
Unfortunately,
we don't know what their writing system
is.
Okay?
So, if they had writing, and we don't we
can't know for sure if they had writing,
it was like Chinese in an ideographic
language.
Meaning it is not phonological.
Their speaking
their spoken language is not the same as
their written language.
In other words, it is impossible for us
to de- to decipher
their written language.
We don't have that
um
many artifacts of writing. We have seals
with um characters uh written on them,
but we don't have anything else.
And the reason could be uh if you look
at Egypt, they they used papyrus, okay?
And papyrus uh is stable or it keeps uh
in in the dry Egyptian air, okay? If you
look at uh Sumerian culture,
Mesopotamian culture, they used
cuneiform on clay tablets, which keeps
forever, okay? But if they had a writing
system and they did write, it would be
on palm leaves, which degrades very
easily in the
um air.
Okay? So, we don't have access to their
writing.
This is problematic because without
access to their writing, we don't have
access to their religion.
We don't know what their religion is.
And one thing that you learn in this
class that's very important is religion
or mythology, it is the operating system
of the culture.
Okay? It is the collective
consciousness, the collective worldview
that gives life to their culture. It
explains why they do what they do.
And unfortunately, we don't know their
religion.
Okay?
But
so, it's a complete mystery
to
arch- archaeologists, to scholars, as to
why this very advanced civilization was
very peaceful and very egalitarian. We
can only speculate.
All right. Any questions so far before I
continue?
Okay. So,
um
I'm going to speculate as to why they
were peaceful and
egalitarian.
Um so,
what So, again,
the key is their religion. What is their
religion? Because that will give us
clues as to their mentality, their value
system, right?
We know that the Mesopotamian people,
their religion focused on struggle and
achievement. We know that the Egyptians,
their religion focused on the afterlife,
okay? Uh this life that we live is
we it it the what what's important is
not the here and now, what's important
is what happens
afterwards, okay? That's And that's why
the Egyptians built the pyramid, that's
why they focused so much on funeral
rights and on burial goods.
All right? So,
there had to be religion in the IBC
that was different from the belief
system in Sumer and Egypt that made it
into a peaceful and egalitarian
um
uh civilization, okay?
All right.
So, what is this religion and why were
they different?
My speculation is this. The key is to
understand that this is a civilization
based on trade.
And they've been traders
um ever since they were born as as a
culture. Meaning they were trading for
at least 7,000 8,000 years before they
became a civilization.
Okay? And if you're a trader,
um
first of all, you're able to access the
entire world.
So, we know for a fact they traded with
Sumer and the Persian Gulf states
because we have we have
um artifacts from the IBC in these
places, okay? We know for a fact. We can
speculate that they also traded with
Egypt and with China just based on their
technology and um their trade networks.
So, this is a civilization based on
trade.
And as as traders, they're able to see
what's going on in Mesopotamia and
Egypt. They know they built the pyramids
in Egypt. They know there's massive
warfare in Sumer.
And I would think that if you were a
trader and you saw these things,
you wouldn't be impressed, okay? In
fact, you might be disgusted, especially
by the warfare in Mesopotamia. This idea
called the dialectic, right?
And I think this is a very important
idea for us to appreciate how history is
often driven by the idea of the
dialectic.
So, an example that we have in today's
world is you look at Japan and China,
okay? These are
two vastly different societies that are
next to each other.
And the question then is why they're so
different? I think the answer is because
Japan knows China very well.
And a lot of cultural practice um Japan
developed over over uh the centuries
have been in response to what they see
as failings or successes in Chinese
culture, okay?
Another example that um they will
appreciate is Canada and the United
States.
The United States is probably the most
belligerent nation
in the world, okay? They cannot keep
their hands off anything.
And then you go north, Canada, and you
know, Canada and the United States share
the world's longest border.
Basically, Canadians are cousins of the
of of the Americans, okay? I mean, like
there's really no difference. We speak
the same language, with the same
cultural practices.
Um but while Americans are the most
belligerent nation ever in human
history, Canadians invented
peacekeeping, okay? The idea
like nations should strive for meditate
for
uh mediation and and peace, okay? And
and I think a lot of Canada, a lot of
Canadian values, uh especially
especially its political system, is
really in response to what it believes
to be failings and successes in American
model, okay? You also have New Zealand
and uh Australia. So, there are many
different examples of of the dialectic
going on in our global political
systems.
And I believe that's what happened with
the IBC, where these traders saw what's
happening in Egypt and saw what's
happening in Mesopotamia, and they were
kind of disgusted, especially by all
this warfare in
uh Mesopotamia, okay?
Um
warfare back then
was pretty awful.
And so, in Mesopotamia, uh the way they
fight is they fight with these um clay
bullets,
okay? And you take a you take a
slingshot and you throw it at someone.
And these things kill. They hurt. So,
think of David and Goliath, okay? And if
you're a trader, um
you know, you'll see this warfare going
on. You'll see people being uh beheaded.
And why are they doing this? They're
doing it in the name of God, okay? Every
city-state has a patron god
that it believes it must defend
uh and honor and protect. And whenever
whenever there's a there's there's a
dispute, it's because they feel their
god has been dishonored by another
city-state. So, they go go to war and
they kill each other,
okay?
And again, if you're a trader and you
see this, you don't think this is a good
thing.
Um and you go to Egypt and you see these
pyramids, and these pyramids are again,
extremely impressive. But at the same
time, you also need to see the
consequences of these pyramids, which is
just massive inequality, massive
corruption, just massive waste.
All right? So,
I think that by trading with these two
civilizations and other civilizations,
um it reinforces
the deep cultural values of the IBC
people and it and it basically compels
them towards peace and egalitarianism.
Okay? That's what I believe happened.
All right? Now, you could there are
there are other arguments,
uh for example, maybe
um
uh these people are just genetically
peaceful and egalitarian.
But I've made the argument in this class
that from the onset of early human
history, we were peaceful and
egalitarian people.
But uh different geographic
circumstances changed our outlook, okay?
So, for example,
uh the people in the steppes, who we
call the Anat people, because of the
grasslands, because it is such a poor
and rugged and unforgiving environment,
they're forced to be cattle ranchers.
They're forced to engage in cattle
raiding, okay? And over time,
their culture became very
aggressive,
expansionist,
and
opportunistic.
Opportunistic just means
they'll do whatever it needs to survive.
If they face a
um
they'll trade with people if it if it's
that if that's what benefits them.
They'll kill people if that's what
benefits them. They are not that moral,
okay? They're very optimistic
opportunistic. And and as and I
remember, as I said, these people with
their cultural values would go in
and conquer all of Europe in about 200
300 years, okay? And they were they were
called the Anat people.
Uh back in the steppes, these Anat
people continued to evolve over time,
and over time,
they became even more aggressive, more
expansionist, and more opportunistic,
okay? Eventually, the Mongols, Genghis
Khan and the Mongols, will
um come from this civilization, okay?
So, that's my argument to you. And
again, uh it's my speculation.
It is because of their interaction with
other cultures that convinced them to
pursue a peaceful and egalitarian
lifestyle. Now, there are still
inequalities
in IBC. We know there are classes. We
know there is wealth inequality. But
relative to Mesopotamia and Egypt, it
was a real it was it was a relatively
peaceful
and egalitarian society.
Okay?
Okay, any questions before I continue?
Okay, so the question is
were they invaded
uh the IBC, okay? Because
um
in previous classes,
when you're a peaceful and egalitarian
society, we know that Old Europe, okay?
Before the Anat invasion, was a peaceful
and egalitarian society.
You eventually get invaded by other
cultures.
Okay? And for the longest time,
um there was a theory out there
uh first proposed by
uh basically the Nazis, okay? Called the
Indo-Aryan
invasion.
The idea is you have these white people
sweep into India,
conquer the people, and introduce
civilization to the Indians,
okay? This is called the Indo-Aryan
invasion.
Even though this theory has been
discredited,
there is a slight kernel of truth to
this theory, okay? Which I shall explain
to you.
Okay? So,
let me explain this theory and what
happened. So, you have the IBC,
which is a very advanced civilization.
The problem with this civilization is
their entire economy is especially based
on trade,
right?
Now, we know
in about uh there's something called the
um 4.2 kiloyear event,
which is which is just basically a
massive climate change around the world.
And the 4.2 kiloyear event brought
basically an end to the Egypt Old
Kingdom,
right?
It also brought an end to what we call
the Akkadian Empire in Sumer. A man
named Sargon of Akkad conquered all of
Sumer and built the Akkadian Empire. And
because of this of this drought, because
of climate change, their his empire
collapsed, Okay?
So, in other words, trade networks that
the IVC heavily dependent on
um start to collapse.
Okay?
And as a result
their cities now, which are dependent on
trade, start to uh depopulate. Meaning a
lot a lot of people start to return to
the farms where they are from. They
start also uh migrating
uh to the rest of uh India, to the
Ganges.
Okay?
As well, because of this climate change
the IVC itself is being affected
heavily. Okay? So, there's drought.
Um
the rivers are drying up. Remember, like
the Indus Valley Civilization is called
the Indus Valley Civilization because
it's dependent on the Indus River, among
other rivers. Okay? So, there are some
drought issues.
Also, what we learn in this class is
over time all civilizations face
internal tensions.
Okay? And these internal tensions can be
divided into two uh major tensions. The
first tension is a conflict among the
classes. Okay? So, the idea of elite
over overproduction.
You have too many people striving for
limited status, right? And the conflict
is mainly between upper nobility
and lower nobility.
Okay? And so, here in the IVC, we can
imagine the conflict might be might be
between these families that are large
trading houses
against families that are small trading
houses. Okay? Or it could be
like internal internally among the
families. Okay? But there's going to be
some social tension going on.
The other social tension that we
discussed is the idea of rat utopia.
Where and especially conflict between
the old and the young.
Again, the problem with the IVC is you
have too many old people living for too
long. Which means less opportunities
arise for achievement for the young.
Okay? And that creates conflict as well.
So, what we believe that it also is that
during this time there was massive
social tension
within the IVC.
And some people would even say it was a
revolutionary time, okay? When old
customs and old morals were being
overthrown.
Okay?
Because of climate change, the people in
the Indo-Aryan culture now are forced to
leave the steps because the steps are no
longer suitable for their lifestyle.
Okay? So, they push into the Oxus Valley
Civilization and over time
they will assimilate it into themselves.
Okay? So, um the idea here is this is
not an intentional
invasion. Okay? It's not like you have a
general in an army and they go into the
Oxus Valley Civilization and then they
conquer it. Okay? It's more
opportunistic. Where at first they're
trading and as the Oxus Valley
Civilization declines because of trade
trading networks um because of declining
trading networks, they will start to
come in and push out the people. And
again, the culture of these of these
people is very aggressive. So, there are
two strategies that they will employ.
The first strategy is they might wipe
out villages. Okay? These villages are
depopulated anyway. They come in and
they wipe everyone out, which means they
kill everyone. The second strategy is
they'll come in, they'll kill all the
men and marry all the women.
Okay?
And again, this is a gradual process of
assimilation, cultural
uh conquest.
It's not a military invasion. Okay? Does
that make sense?
Now, after the Indo-Aryan culture and
the Oxus culture
um merge, this creates a new
civilization, a new culture called
Proto-
Indo-
Iranian.
Okay? Why is it called that? Because now
what they will do is they'll go south to
the Iranian Plateau and they will become
eventually the Persian people.
Okay? And they will invent a new
religion that becomes a great world
world religion called Zoroastrianism.
Zoroastrianism comes from this
uh merger of um the Proto-Iranian
culture into the Iranian Plateau. This
is a process we call syncretization, by
the way.
Syncretization.
Where two major religions merge and
share the same gods.
And there are three distinct
characteristics of the
Proto-Indo-Iranian culture that becomes
salient in the new Zoroastrianism
religion. Okay? The first is the use of
a ritual drink called Soma.
Okay? Soma.
Okay? Again, you don't have to know
this, but I'm I'm just telling you the
cultural impact. Okay? Soma is comes
from the Proto-Indo-Iranian culture.
Second is the the worship of fire. Okay?
Fire rituals.
Fires are used um heavily in
uh their religious practice. Okay? And
as we know, Zoroastrianism does use a
lot of fire rituals. The last is uh
horse sacrifice. Meaning that warriors
are buried with their horses.
And so, this is an emphasis on the
warrior culture of these people.
Okay?
So, that's what happens in Iran. They
they they become the Persian people. We
will discuss the Persian people at a
later point. Okay? Not now, but but I
just want you to know this is what
happened.
They These people will also push into
the IVC. And over time, and this is a
process that takes about 500 years,
they'll push out the
uh indigenous people. Okay?
And then the indigenous people move into
South India, where they merge with the
folk culture, the animism of the local
people there. Okay?
And guys, what's amazing about this is
this process will create two major world
religions that are still um influential
today. Okay? The first we know as
Hinduism.
Hinduism
is the merger, the syncretization of
Proto-Indo-Aryan uh religion with the
local IVC religion. Okay?
And as the IVC pushes south, this will
create a new religion
called Buddhism. Okay?
All right?
But Buddhism is just the major one.
There are others that are being created
as well through this process, right? The
others are being Jainism
and Sikhism.
And again, these are the major ones,
okay? That are still with us today.
Like basically, this process created
thousands tens of thousands of new
religions.
All right?
So, this is what happened. It's not a
military conquest. It's not an invasion,
but it's a process of you could argue
cultural genocide, okay? Where new
people come in and over time, because
they are aggressive, expansionist,
opportunistic culture, they will
eventually take over the culture. Okay?
Mainly by
um marrying the local women because the
people who come in are basically
basically males, okay? They will marry
the local women
and they will either kill
or enslave the local men. And this is
where we get the caste system from in
India.
All right? So, so this this is
a more subtle
explanation
of the Indo-Aryan invasion theory.
And this is what scholars today accept
happened. And again,
um what's really important is to avoid
generalizations
and simplifications because this is a
process that took about 300 years, 400
years, and there were different
strategies employed by different people.
Some of it was peaceful, some of it was
violent. Okay? It was a mix. It's hard
for us to generalize. But the overall
general effect is
uh the creation of Hinduism and
Buddhism.
Which now are the two major world
religions.
Okay? Any questions?
But but thanks for the question, Echo.
Any any more questions
before I move on?
I've got a few, but I I think I'll I'll
save them till the end. Uh
actually, you can ask cuz cuz cuz I I'll
I'll I'll I'll have some time to to
rest.
All right. Uh so, this so one question
has to do with the idea that the
IVC were were were peaceful, Mhm. right?
And
egalitarian and so on. Yep. But at the
same time, they're a trading nation.
That's right.
And and so, I'm just wondering as as
traders
like quite often, you know, your trading
involves an empire or at least involves
having some amount of force on your side
to protect yourself
Yep. from competitors or
pirates or
Yep. or whatever.
Is there is there any evidence that,
while peaceful, they still had a certain
amount of might on on their side
Okay. So, uh that's a good question,
Doug. Okay? So,
when you trade, there's always a problem
of piracy and banditry, right? So, how
do you protect yourselves against that?
Okay, we know like Mesopotamia
became violent because it was it was
being surrounded by violence, right? The
nomads in Arabia, the nomads in the
Zagros Mountains were all pretty violent
people. You had to be because to
survive, you have to be aggressive and
opportunistic.
So, how is it the um
um sorry, the IBC was able to be
peaceful
yet at the same time trade? And the
solution is
they set up colonies
and trade partners in order to
facilitate trade. Okay? So, we know for
example, they traded heavily with the
Oxus civilization. There were lots of
trade agreements, long-term trade
agreements. We also know they had a
colony within the Oxus Valley
civilization.
Okay? We know they traded heavily with a
place called Dilmun, which is now
modern-day Iraq. Okay? So, these are
their main trading partners. And so, you
would think their trading partners were
the ones who were responsible for local
security.
Okay?
Um
we can also suspect they also went to
other places well to seek new trading
partners. What's important about this
world is this is still a relatively
peaceful world. There's tremendous
violence in Sumer, but that's still
rare. Right? And there are some unique
um
characteristics about Sumer that make it
a violent people. But in this world, and
this is about 5,000 years ago,
people are still relatively peaceful.
Organized warfare is still
uh new and rare in the human experience.
And that's why I think the experience in
Mesopotamia was so shocking because
the idea that you could uh sack a city,
the idea that you could kill hundreds of
people at one time,
that's like breaking a massive cultural
taboo. Okay? So, I think culturally
speaking, people at this time prefer to
trade rather than to fight. And because
they've been trading for such a long
time, we're talking like, you know, they
start maybe trading about 7,000, 6,000
BCE,
they have a lot of trading networks
around the world. They have partners
they can trust, basically.
Okay?
Okay. Any Any more questions before I
continue?
Maybe one more, but I I might be
anticipating a little bit, but but but
you know, people here know a little bit
about Buddhism and stuff, right? Yeah,
I'm actually moving into Buddhism.
I'll I'll save it for later. Okay. Any
But any more questions before I
continue?
Okay. So, the last thing I I want I want
to discuss is what is the legacy of the
IBC? They were a great civilization. Um
are they completely lost to us? What is
their contribution to Western
civilization?
So, the legacy of Egypt are the
pyramids, right? We know Egypt because
of the pyramids. The legacy of
Mesopotamia are many. They They invented
a lot of things like writing,
cuneiform.
Also, they introduced world literature,
right? The Epic of Gilgamesh.
What I want to argue
uh now is the legacy of the IBC is in
their spiritual spiritual practice.
Okay? Their spiritual
um
values.
So,
if you look at Hinduism,
okay? It's very different from
Zoroastrianism. And that's kind of
strange because
they're both proto-Indo-Iranian
religions, right? But let's look at very
quickly at Hinduism.
Hinduism believes uh the reality we live
in is false. Okay?
Uh the real reality is called Brahman,
the true absolute
reality.
So, we live in this false reality.
As we live in this false reality,
um we collect karma.
Karma's basically just an accounting of
your good deeds and your bad deeds. And
guess what? Throughout your life, you're
going to accumulate more bad deeds than
you are than your good deeds. And your
karma
uh means your soul, called the atman,
is stuck here. Okay? Because the
Brahman, it's pure. You can only You can
only return to Brahman to heaven if
you're a pure person. So, it will take
many lifetimes for you to cleanse your
soul, your atman, in order to return to
the Brahman.
This process of
um cleansing your soul is what they call
dharma. Okay? Dharma.
The right path.
Um if you if the dharma over thousands
of lifetimes, if your dharma
is correct, if you achieve dharma, you
will achieve what is called moksha,
which is basically liberation. Moksha
releases you, your soul, from the
physical world and allows you to return
to the Brahman where you will live
eternally in paradise.
Okay? That is the
um
one of the basic ideas of Hinduism.
Another really important idea of
Hinduism is
this entire process
is being meditated or sorry, mediated
or gatekept by priests called Brahmans.
Okay?
So, you think being a good person is
enough. No, it's not. You have to listen
to the Brahman because only the Brahman
understands dharma.
Okay? And depending on who you are, your
dharma will be different.
So,
in uh Hinduism, there's a hierarchy.
Okay?
Um at the very top are of course the
priest, the Brahman, because they have
access to spiritual knowledge. Below
them
are the warriors and the kings.
And then below them are the farmers and
the merchants
who keep the economy
uh running. And then at the very bottom
are the servants and the laborers. Okay?
Now, what's What's really interesting
about this system is
this system can be differentiated by the
color of one's skin.
Right? Because remember,
the proto-Indo-Iranians,
they have white skin. The IBC culture,
the people who call the
proto-Dravidians, no, sorry, the
proto-Dravidians, okay? They have darker
skin.
So,
the IBC people of the lower class don't
intermix with the
the proto-Indo-Iranians.
And so, basically the
proto-Indo-Iranians
um
accumulated and centralized power
through the idea of Hinduism, okay?
They're the priest class.
So, that's the basic theory
of Hinduism. And again, Hinduism is an
extremely complex religion. I don't want
to oversimplify it,
uh but I have no choice because I want
to explain the differences, okay?
So, in this system,
who's really unhappy now?
In this system, which group of people
are like very upset
with this system?
Can you guys Can you Can you guys echo?
Can you Can you apply what we've learned
in this semester and answer the
question,
all these four groups, who's unhappiest?
And who who most wants change or
revolutionary change?
The lower nobility.
Excuse me? The lower nobility. The lower
nobility. And who's the lower lower no
no nobility in this system?
Uh
The kings, okay? Does that make sense?
The kings actually in this system are
the lower nobility. The upper nobility
are the Brahmans.
Because the upper Because it's the
Brahmans who control access to the
Brahman, okay? And so, the kings must
obey the priests. So, the kings are
unhappy with this.
And so, from this conflict, you have the
creation of Buddhism, right?
Remember,
Siddhartha uh Gautama, who's considered
the first first Buddha, he was actually
a prince before he became the Buddha.
And the man most responsible for
spreading Buddhism in India and around
the world, his name is Sho is Ashoka. He
was the king, the emperor of the Mauryan
Empire.
And he was the one who institu-
institutionalized Buddhism as the state
religion, who sponsored sponsored
missionary projects to China, to Greece,
to Egypt.
Okay? So, these rulers
don't like Hinduism because they see the
Brahman class as a threat to their
power.
So, Buddhism follows
this system except for one major
difference. You don't need the Brahmans
to access nirvana.
Okay? You don't need the Brahmans to
access spiritual enlightenment. You can
do it by yourself through spiritual
guidance by monks. Okay? That's a major
difference.
As you can see, Buddhism
is in many respects a revolutionary
religion to overthrow
the power of the Brahman class.
In response to Buddhism,
what did the Brahmins do?
Do you guys know?
They create the caste system, okay?
After the rise of Buddhism,
Hinduism started to implement what we
call today the caste system.
Which is to say, these classes
must
separate from each other. They are not
allowed to intermingle. They're not even
allowed to touch each other. They're not
even allowed to touch each other's food,
okay? This goes at the very bottom of
what we call today the untouchables.
This system was developed by the Hindu
priests, the Brahmins, in response to
the threat of Hinduism.
Now, over time, because Hinduism, like
the Proto-Iranian people, are
aggressive, expansionist, opportunistic,
they will defeat Buddhism in the
struggle, okay? And the one way One
really important way they defeat
Buddhism is
by adopting most of Buddhism's
um
practices, okay? So, like yoga,
meditation,
um and also nirvana, okay? The Hindu
Brahmins will adopt whatever is popular
in Buddhism.
Another thing that the Hindu priests
will do is they will start
um
uh basically assimilating other
religions as well.
So, most Indians,
throughout its history, believed in
their folk local folklore gods, right?
Eventually, all these gods will be
assimilated into the Hindu hierarchy.
That's why you have like a million gods
in the Hindu religion, okay? Because
they were all, over time, assimilated
into the hierarchy. And obviously, uh
these gods are lesser gods. The higher
gods, the Holy Trinity,
uh are Brahmin gods.
Okay.
All right. So, now's your chance for
uh
Bhakta to ask his
question about about Buddhism before I
continue. Yeah, yeah, yes. So, maybe
it's a good good chance that I can
go back to the
point about the
IBC
that was not knowing their
religion. Yeah.
Um
so, way way back a month ago, you were
you were talking about the
Proto-Indo-European
language. That's right.
Right? And there's been a lot of
archaeological work That's right. to put
that
that together, right? Yep. Do you know
if there's been a similar concept
process looking at the different
Indian religions, like Hinduism,
Buddhism, Jainism? Yeah. And and is is
there a certain common denominator that
perhaps could be traced back to the IBC?
Okay, great question, okay? So, so what
is the IBC religion, the Proto religion?
Okay.
Um I want to make an argument, and
again, it's
uh speculation.
It's a very strange argument, and most
scholars probably will not agree.
I think
the religion of the IBC
is Proto Buddhism.
And the reason why is
if you look at Zoroastrianism,
and you look at Proto-Indo-Iranian,
the religion, there are a lot of
similarities, okay? And Proto
Zoroastrianism actually fits into the
larger Proto-Indo-European
religion framework.
When you look at Hinduism,
you've got this strange idea, you a
belief in karma, dharma, reincarnation,
impermanence,
Brahma, the ultimate reality.
Like Like this is not part of the
Proto-Indo-European
religion in anywhere, okay?
So,
but at the same time, Hinduism,
Buddhism, Jainism, and Sikhism all share
this funda- fundamental belief in the
world, that this world is
um a false reality. It's a reality
created by our false beliefs.
And if we learn to tame our emotions, if
we learn to to see the underlying
reality governing all
uh human structure, then we will be
released from this world, okay?
Now, where would that come from? That
must have come from the IBC, because
there there would be no other place.
Also, it explains why these religions
have such huge followings in India,
right? They don't have any followings
anywhere else.
Okay?
Like Hinduism is basically localized to
uh India. So is Jainism, so is Sikhism.
So, they are appealing to a fundamental
sense of the world among Indians.
They're basically appealing to a
nostalgia,
right? And where is this nostalgia from?
It's It must be be from the IBC.
Okay? So, I would make that argument. I
would I would I would believe I would
bet
that if we were able to construct the
religion of the IBC, the Proto religion,
we would see a
Proto
Buddhism, okay? The beginnings of
Buddhism. It would be very different,
okay? Because Buddhism evolved over
thousands of years.
But the underlying assumptions about the
world,
um basically the idea of
oneness, okay?
Okay? The idea of false reality.
I think these two ideas would be very
apparent
in the IBC, as they are apparent now in
all four major Indian religions:
Hinduism, Buddhism, Jainism, and
Sikhism.
Okay?
Do Do you want to
continue or
No, no, no, no, no, I'm finished, but
like like do you want to respond to to
my argument?
No, it makes sense makes sense to me.
Okay.
And and and are you guys following
along?
Does this make sense to you guys?
In fact,
I would argue
that we as humans
fundamentally have a nostalgia for these
two ideas: oneness and false reality,
okay? Because if you look at the West,
okay? If you look at us today,
there are two ideas
that are the most powerful
today in Western civilization.
The first idea is Plato's
allegory of the cave.
Right?
The idea that we live in a shallow
world,
and the truth is out there, but we have
to seek it.
It's a very powerful idea.
Right? And it's very similar, by the
way, to the ideas found in Hinduism and
Buddhism, okay? The allegory of the cave
is the first powerful idea. And then the
second powerful idea is the idea of the
second coming.
The return of Jesus.
Because what does the return of Jesus
signify? It signifies paradise on Earth.
It signifies the destruction of our
current reality and the replacement of a
new reality that creates oneness,
completeness, and wholeness on Earth.
So, in many ways,
um this is very similar to
what the Indians are proposing as well.
So,
what this is saying is
at a fundamental level,
everyone has a nostalgia for a distant
past.
Okay? And what is this distant past?
The distant past is the idea of animism.
So, remember, 10,000 years ago, 20,000
years ago,
we were in the Ice Age. We were
hunter-gatherers.
And the way we saw the world was very
different from the way we we see the
world today,
okay? Back then, if you were a
hunter-gatherer, you could only think
you were you were the same as the tree
or as the animal, okay? It's the idea of
oneness. We're no different.
We're all part of the life cycle.
We're all part of
uh Mother Nature, okay? The Mother
Goddess.
All right? We also believe
we inhabit different realities at the at
the same time, right? We live in this
world, which is the material reality,
but we could we were also inhabiting a
spiritual reality as well. And what we
do spiritually matters a lot more than
what we do materially, okay?
So, we can hunt and kill animals as long
as we pay the proper respects to the
animals we kill.
As long as we
um contribute spiritually
to the cycle cycle of life and death.
Okay?
So, I think that's where Buddhism comes
from. It comes from animism.
And this Buddhism this Proto Buddhism
became reinforced and became uh much
more concrete because
it was experiencing
a reality in Mesopotamia and Egypt that
was abhorrent to the people
experiencing, okay?
War goes against the human experience.
Inequality and corruption and waste goes
against the human experience. We
fundamentally believe
this to be evil and wrong.
Okay?
So, that that is my
argument about the IBC.
Any questions?
A- any
comments?
You seem to believe that human
Okay, that's a good question. Do I
believe that human nature is
fundamentally benevolent?
I don't believe human nature is is
benevolent. I believe humans naturally
seek a spiritual understanding of the
world.
I think humans want to know why. Why are
we here?
Where are we going?
Where do we come from? Okay? We want to
know why.
We also we're also curious. We want to
explore the world. Okay, so I think
trade is not a new invention. I think
it's a very
inherent thing to human nature. I think
the idea of idea of globalization, this
was a globalized world like 5,000 years
ago, okay? Extremely sophisticated,
complex, globalized world.
So, I think that's what makes us
fundamentally fundamentally human.
Okay? And you can say this is a good
thing or a bad thing. And I would say,
well, it depends on the circumstance,
right? But I think what drives us as
humans is our curiosity
and our
um
our imagination.
Okay? That's what I think being human
is. And sometimes this is a good thing.
Sometimes it's a bad thing, okay?
Sometimes
in the IVC, this will lead to peace and
egalitarianism. But this also is what
drives the idea of the second coming,
which is what's driving the conflict in
the Middle East today.
Okay? So, it depends on the context, it
depends on the circumstance. If it if
this curiosity, this imagination is
channeled effectively, then I think
that's a good thing.
If it's channeled
opportunistically,
then it's a bad thing.
Okay?
Okay, but thanks thanks for the
question. Any more questions?
Okay.
Um so, this ends our Bronze Age unit,
okay? So, we've looked at the three
major Bronze Age civilizations, Egypt,
Mesopotamia,
and um IVC.
Next class, we'll start the Bible, okay?
The Hebrew Bible.
All right.